liberal media bias on full display the
press shaming republicans over election
challenges while giving joe biden the
softball treatment
take a look at these attacks on the gop
the republican senators
who are still silent about biden's win
they're enablers too
and here is the list we're going to
leave this up for a second because it is
rather long i think those people in his
administration
that not only drafted some of those
policies
but were complicit i don't think that
they should be forgotten and i don't
think that we should
look the other way i do think that
people need to be held accountable
for their actions now compare that with
these softball questions for joe biden
will you move ahead if the president
continues to refuse to concede
how do you expect to be able to work
with republicans when so many
have thus far refused to even
acknowledge your victory what do you say
to the americans that are anxious over
the fact that president trump has yet to
concede and what that might mean for the
country
well those are some tough questions
brian i don't know i don't know if you
can even answer those hard-hitting
questions right
a couple of things at least we didn't
get what enchants you most about the job
you're about to do
i actually don't mind those questions i
just wish more of those questions were
asked to the president
to give him a second to reflect and
maybe find out something about him
rather than
uh what do the russians know like why do
you why are you in melania you're not
staying in the same house and
what's happening why is uh why is baron
so tall all those questions
he never had an easy question in four
years but he's getting it here's the
other thing
who cares if someone in the view doesn't
like you and is going to target you i
don't think she's hiring anyway
the other thing is you put up a list of
people who haven't endorsed the
president
and you expect is this like some mystery
thing a murder she wrote
that doesn't matter we know they haven't
endorsed yet they're still counting
ballots
everyone's cancelling so many people you
can't even keep up with we got to
get a thicker skin stop targeting people
that's your problem
but overall i like the dana perino
method of
i don't care i don't check my voicemail
i don't check my
text messages i'm not on social media
it's hard to know
who's mad at me when i don't care i got
to i'm tapping into perino magic
maybe that's why dana doesn't call me
back
[Laughter]
dana what do you think about the
language brian was talking about putting
people on lists i don't like the word
he's an enabler or they're complicit and
they need to be held
accountable what does that remind you of
well i think
there's there's um in history you could
go back and find
examples of that like i'm not for
canceling anybody uh except for maybe
like two people
i can think of off the top right gutfeld
would be one
i think that this whole idea of canceled
culture actually really did
hurt the democrats um and it's not just
because
of any individuals it's that whole
feeling of this is not how
how we were raised this is not like if
if you um
believe in a higher power that's not how
you're taught
to treat other people and just because
somebody decided to go work on
let's say at the national park service
under a trump administration they
deserve to be canceled that doesn't make
any sense to me cancel the park service
katie i can imagine that if joe was down
and he was filing legal challenges the
media would be getting us back
and making sure that every vote was
counted before the certification
yeah i don't think we'd be declaring
anything uh that we are now but i think
that they would also be
backing his decision and saying that the
president shouldn't be celebrating yet i
mean
we know that the media is biased that
there's a double standard i think though
if things turn out the way that they've
been called to turn out that
the press is going to miss president
trump you already have
uh reporters saying that they're not
getting call readouts with foreign
leaders that joe biden is supposedly
making
you have reminders that during the obama
administration they were spying
on reporters the justice department went
after more sources under the espionage
act than ever before
i think they're going to miss the access
and the transparency and the president
coming out multiple times a day
and talking to reporters giving them the
sound bites i need giving them the
the thoughts giving them everything they
need to to be successful in their jobs
um i think we'll they'll be missing him
yeah one i mean the president made a lot
of media people stars
the way they had these really robust
exchanges on tv
you know the books that were written did
have a list of people to call on
right i mean we used to just sit here
and watch these just brawls between the
press and the president
and people made big names for themselves
now they're just whining that they're
not even getting any access
do you think katie's right and the press
may miss president trump just a little
bit
i think mr deep dive might miss this
president a little bit
right i think they'll do i think but i
don't think look i think that the
reality is first
that i don't like lists just let me say
that i think that the whole notion of
you know people being held accountable
is legitimate but
enemies list targeting people i think
that's the opposite of what we need in a
free society in terms of open debate and
tolerance i don't like it
i don't also don't like though when you
see people who refuse to say
oh there was an election there's no
evidence of fraud and i
acknowledge a fair result and here
therefore i acknowledge president-elect
joe biden and it's too many republicans
right now
in republican leadership in washington
are refusing to do it i don't know if
they think this is going to generate
excitement in the base for the georgia
race
i don't know what they're doing but it's
not in keeping with our democratic norms
it's not in keeping with giving the
incoming administration the opportunity
to have a peaceful successful transition
and today i read in the paper something
very interesting about what happened
after that 2000 race where you had that
month-long count in florida
that the people on the 911 commission
said the
failure to have a speedy efficient
transition
opened the door to some of the damage
that we as a nation suffered in 9 11.
i think that's truly damaging jesse and
i think people should be held
accountable and said
stop it we had a real election we have a
winner
let's go one i have a con a question
sure if
if the president did come out and and
congratulate joe biden but also said but
i want
lawsuits to move forward to do an
analysis and audit of these elections
considering they changed the rules in
the middle of the game
we have a new election system in a
number of these important states with
all these mail-in ballots
we have studies that show that they're
prone to fraud would you be okay with
that would you be okay with looking at
what went on
sure you can make sure that things are
on the up and up but katie you can look
at things but again
you don't say that i am refusing to
concede
i am acting like i'm somebody tyrion
leader i'm the king
that and all right maybe what we'll do
is they'll just send fbi agents to the
biden transition team
oh yeah